retrouver pour en parler en direct de
Shanghai notre correspondante look qui
si elle a le bonjour des mots très forts
ce matin était prononcé
oui et ce alors que depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine les mots sont au
contraire très prudents et très mesurés
mais tout à l'heure lors de sa
conférence de presse wanguy s'est montré
un peu plus clair le ministre des
Affaires étrangères chinois affirme que
la relation entre la Chine et la Russie
et je cite solide comme un roc il dit
même que la relation bilatérale est
l'une des plus importantes des plus
cruciales au monde et il affirme que les
perspectives de coopération entre les
deux pays sont immenses fin de citation
tout ça ça sonne comme un pied de nez
aux sanctions aux économies contre la
Russie et d'ailleurs Pékin a dit si
opposés à plusieurs reprises la Chine se
pose donc de fait comme un allié
économique de la Russie mais toujours
sans soutenir ouvertement ni sans
condamné l'invasion en
Ukraine la Chine reste donc ambivalente
puisqu'elle veut aussi elle se dit aussi
prête à jouer un rôle dans les
négociations pour la paix et elle va
envoyer de l'aide humanitaire en crème
via la Croix-Rouge chinoise
ou comment les les Chinois
réagissent-ils à cette crise
alors c'est difficile à dire puisque ici
la guerre ne fait pas vraiment les gros
titres et sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois la censure est à l'oeuvre c'est
à dire que les commentaires
anti-guerre sont effacées très vite en
revanche les internautes nationalistes
eux peuvent critiquer les États-Unis et
l'OTAN sans problème et la censure ne
touche pas que les Chinois en ce moment
ce sont les Jeux paralympiques de Pékin
et lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
retransmises en direct à la télévision
chinoise le président du Comité
paralympique a tenu un discours au
moment où il mentionne la guerre et bien
son discours n'est plus traduit en
direct à noter aussi que les matchs de
la première ligue anglaise n'ont pas été
diffusées en Chine ce week-end parce que
certains joueurs avaient prévu et bien
de manifester leur soutien à l'Ukraine
merci beaucoup cristiana en direct de
Shanghai on va rester sur